Tên gian trình xử ngà của khuôn nha chính kiến tất đận thái lâu tham mới, bố phòng ngay thông báo,
lực lượng phòng không ở bán 2 bà trà bốn người thí bị bài khuôn người lái cho phòng 2 mi tư sở,
và đánh trạm 3 tên lửa, imiles trong ngày 18 chiến.
Ngà cũng tiến hệ tấn công và cất tơ sở chỉ huy đến tỷ quân đoàn nước ngoài,
bà cơ sở lưu chủ thí bị bài của khuôn nè.
Ở trường lực lại, u khuôn nha cho biết đã chỉnh 2 mi bài khuôn người lái tấn công một tơ sở lập dầu.
Tại thành phố OFA, bộng bác sport tostàn của ngay tên gia vụ nổ lượng và lắm ngã nghiêm trong cơ sở này.
Chính quyết địa phương sang nhận nhà máy tu tập đoàn bác nè, đồng thời cho biết không có thương vòng,
và đam trái đất cơ bản được phục trái.
Các đồng thái tấn công qua lại diễn ra chùa bố cạnh,
nguy phân ngôn diện family Dimitriy Pascop tự bố,
tiến trình đàn phán hoa bình ngà của khuôn nha đàn tham dừng,
khiến chiến vọng xa của xung đột tiếp tục mở mi.